so it literally rained on Trump's parade
over the weekend I totally checked out
of news and politics starting like right
after we finished the July 3rd show
didn't pay attention to anything until
last night when I started preparing for
today's show but I did hear from friends
that it rained and it poured during
Donald Trump's very absurd kind of diss
dictator esque military parade involving
tanks and so many other things but the
real hilarity was actually in Donald
Trump's speech where he said lots of
things that just made no sense
whatsoever this is just the funniest
dumbest thing which tells us that Donald
Trump is ignorant not just on the big
stuff relationships between countries
and issues of foreign policy and trade
and economics and social issues and on
and on and on and on he's also ignorant
just about basic human timelines in a
sense Donald Trump in his speech meant
to I guess be inspiring called
the salute to America on the 4th of July
mentioned the heroic Continental Army
taking over yes airports during the
Revolutionary War for independence from
England and of course there were no
planes or airports in the 1700s but that
I guess doesn't really matter check this
out and the explanation which I'll play
for you later is even funnier the
Continental Army suffered a bitter
winter of Valley Forge found glory
across the waters of the Delaware and
seized victory from Cornwallis of
Yorktown our army man the air it R and
the ramparts it took over the air ports
it did everything it had to do and at
Fort McHenry yeah what on earth is this
guy talking about airports in the 1700s
I received a really funny email about
this from Gordon Gordon said dear David
I'm a 325 year-old air traffic
controller and I wish to protest that
nobody told me that there was a job for
me at any of the multitudes of airports
in the USA in the 18th century in order
to make ends meet I was forced to drive
a tank at the Battle of Yorktown whilst
my brethren through soot flew supersonic
jet fighters from the nearby
nuclear-powered aircraft carrier if I
had known about these airports I would
have jumped into my Tesla to get to the
ATCO recruitment office in
Tower best wishes Gordon Bain so the the
explanation from the Trump
administration is that the teleprompter
was faulty for a moment now that's funny
because that could mean two different
things
are they saying that a faulty
teleprompter incorrectly added a line
about Revolutionary War era airports
that would be a weird thing like
normally when things glitch they don't
put up coherent language that points to
in accurate historical assertions that
would be a weird sort of glitch for a
teleprompter the other explanation is
the teleprompter glitched in the sense
that Trump had to ad-lib briefly and
what Trump ad-libbed was that there were
airports in the Revolutionary War
another really strange moment was where
Trump was praising American inventors
and he mentioned the Scottish born
Canadian citizen inventor Alexander
Graham Bell check this out our quest for
greatness unleashed a culture of
discovery that led Thomas Edison to
imagine his lightbulb Alexander Graham
Bell to create the telephone the Wright
brothers to look to the sky and see the
next great frontier for Americans
nothing is impossible
so really strange to talk about how
great Americans are at inventing stuff
on the fourth of July and mention
Alexander Graham Bell who of course was
Scottish and moved to Canada where he
was a citizen when he invented the
telephone again this did not seem to be
a teleprompter glitch it actually seemed
to be part of the script or Donald Trump
ad libbing himself both of which raised
a number of questions another
embarrassment and as a reminder because
so much of this is related to
teleprompters failing or Trump reading
strange things from the teleprompter
remember what Donald Trump thought about
Barack Obama's use of a teleprompter one
example from 2012 when Donald Trump
tweeted why does Barack Obama always
have to rely on teleprompter on
teleprompters many other such examples
of course Donald Trump the guy in the
Glass House throwing stones his
teleprompter reportedly glitching and
suddenly Trump thinks there were
airplanes and there
ports in the 1700s here's Donald Trump
blaming the teleprompter give a little
appreciation the media generally
speaking loved it they loved the evening
we had a lot of rain I stood in the rain
the teleprompter went out so ad
yeah the teleprompter went out and kept
going on and then at the end it just
went out it went kaput so I could have
said and actually right in the middle of
that sentence it went out that's not a
good feeling this guy is just the
funniest isn't he despite himself
trumpet if it weren't so embarrassing
internationally day after day after day
he has no fun Ferg for a guy with no
sense of humor whatsoever he is
inadvertently funny in ways that he
can't even understand a president should
not get so confused by a teleprompter
going out that he starts saying there
were airports in the 1700s right is it
is it too much to just expect some basic
knowledge if well the prompter went out
and Trump mentioned that the civil war
was ultimately decided by who had the
better internet technology would we
accept that and say the teleprompter
went out of course he said the Internet
technology at the time determined the
winner of the Civil War no we wouldn't
accept it and this is just as stupid one
of today's sponsors is impeach the card
slap game you can't slap Donald Trump in
real life but you can slap them in this
hilarious fast-paced two-player card
game and you can get it for 10% off when
you go to david pakman.com slash impeach
impeach the card game is awesome for
parties or when you're having a few
drinks I've been playing it with some
friends of mine it combines clever
satire about the Trump administration
with really funny high-quality cartoon
artwork all in a very lively card game
that's easy to learn but it stays
interesting every time you play it
because of how well designed it is and
how much thought went into the humor and
the political commentary impeach the
cards slap game is perfect if you're
looking for something fun and casual to
do with your politically minded friends
or family members it'll make a perfect
gift for anyone you know who has a sense
of humor about Donald Trump don't forget
that Father's Day is coming up and when
you go to david pakman.com slash impeach
not only will you get 10% off the game
you can also get 10% off all of the
other hilarious clothing and accessories
in their online store t-shirts coffee
mugs tote bags featuring funny political
cartoons
about Trump that you can't find anywhere
else get a super fun witty gift for
yourself or someone you know whether
it's impeach the card slap game or
anything else in the gift shop and get
10% off all of it when you go to david
pakman.com slash impeach